[Music]
morning everybody it's seven o'clock is
the party well and truly over for boris
johnson he's given an apology of sorts
for attending a downing street garden
drinks event during lockdown but now
there's a growing number of his own mps
willing to raise a toast to his
departure the northern ireland secretary
brandon lewis will be here in just a few
moments time it is thursday the 13th of
january calling time boris johnson's
future in the balance as he faces calls
to quit from his own backbenchers
i'm live in downing street as boris
johnson fights for his political future
after calls to resign from members of
his own party
a step closer to court virginia duprey's
lawyer say she wants justice as a judge
clears the way for prince andrew to face
a civil sex assault case
feeling the heat the uk's third biggest
gas and electricity supplier ovo plans
to cut a quarter of its workforce as the
energy crisis deepens
according controversy novak djokovic is
included in the delayed draw for the
aussie open but he's still waiting to
find out if he'll be deported
[Music]
ronnie spector the lead singer of the
rinnettes and an icon of american pop
dies after a brief battle with cancer
also on the programme for you
he survived the manchester arena bombing
now he's taking on africa's tallest
mountain we'll speak to the man on a
mission to raise a million pounds for
people living with spinal injuries
and turning the tide on domestic abuse
will speak to the swimmer about her
14-day challenge for women's aid
[Music]
big question this morning can boris
johnson survive let's speak immediately
should we to the northern ireland
secretary brandon lewis happy new year
thanks for joining you look very well
i've been uh quite my wife's been
guiding me to be very sensible with what
i eat over the last couple of months so
it's uh it's uh it's i mean i've lost a
bit of weight which is probably four
stones yes amazing congratulations well
done it suits you um
what is going on with boris johnson what
did he apologize for yesterday if he
said technically he didn't do anything
wrong well i think what he outlined and
rightly so is recognizing that and i you
know something we've all seen in our
constituencies and i see across the
country is the frustration and anger
that people have had at the idea that
people in number 10 were doing one thing
while asking others to do something else
and the pm recognized that wanted to
apologize to that i think as i say
rightly so
yesterday and as he also said we've got
to let the investigation sue grey's
investigation now get to the details so
he can publish that and he'll come back
to parliament and give a full statement
on that but i think he recognized the
feeling in the country and wanted to
reflect he understood that he recognized
that and and and takes on board that
that frustration and anger that people
have
yeah he was saying in the tea room
afterwards to lots of people and i've
had several text messages about it that
he hadn't done anything wrong
well i wasn't in the tea room yes i was
in belfast myself yesterday so i haven't
heard anything
of that so what i saw papers this
morning
what i saw yesterday was the prime
minister
acknowledging and understanding and and
reflecting that he understood the the
feeling that people across the country
would have had with the experiences they
were going through and what they saw
happening and what they've now been
reading about happening at number 10 and
he wanted to reflect that before the
report came out because obviously
there's a strong sense of feeling about
that around the country and i think that
that highlights his understanding of
where the country is and actually why he
is actually the right person to be our
prime minister so it was a boyfriend
apology he was sorry that we were upset
no i think he was recognizing that and
as he himself said yesterday actually
with hindsight that some of the things
that they were doing uh going out and
thanking his staff the way he did with
hindsight is not something he would do
again he should have had them back in
the office carrying work they were doing
he he that's exactly the point he was
making on the floor of the house
yesterday with hindsight he hadn't done
anything wrong but he also was saying
yesterday if you look at what he
actually said on the floor the house
with hindsight he wouldn't have done
that he regrets doing that and he's
apologized for that so he went outside
and he just happened upon
40 people
in the garden he thought that it was a
work meeting so he decided to stay there
for 25 minutes with them even though he
knew what the rules were
well i think if we think i don't know i
appreciate it
times move quite quickly in a way
through kobe but if we go back to 2020
and where things were like i wasn't um
in number 10 around that time but i've
been in number 10 over the years a fair
bit it's a it is a working environment
including i have to say and
the garden itself so i think having the
staff have been working together through
that period trying to make sure the
country of course in a very difficult
period the prime minister himself was
only recently out of hospital
we were still trying to work on getting
the pp i think i'm proud of that time
was probably talking to yourself over
zoom about these things uh the staff
coming together working indoors going
outside going out to thank the staff for
the phenomenal effort that all of that
team will do
well he said he went outside he went to
thank the staff he's said with hindsight
he should have said to him to come back
in
but he went out and thanked the staff
and came back in the garden even though
most people were being told to work from
home well again i think we've got an
investigation from sue grey going
forward that's going to get into all of
the details i can't tell you how many
times your colleagues have mentioned her
name i know who she is we know what i've
said i've worked i've worked with sue
grey over the years in various roles
that both i have had and she has had and
uh she's someone who will be
investigating this without any fear or
favor and when we get the full details
and it's something i know and you and
i've spoken before in previous jobs i've
had as both police minister security
ministries you've got to let these
investigations get to the fact okay
let's put the investigation to one side
we know there's an investigation
everybody keeps banging on about it i
want to know what happened in the garden
of downing street it was a work event a
hundred people were invited if you were
hosting a work event and you invited
your staff and less than half of them
turned up how would you feel about that
well first as was outlined yesterday i
think the prime minister wasn't aware of
the i think of the email that went out
yesterday but again we're starting to
get happened upon them but i'm look
we're starting to get into some of those
details that that investigation is
absolutely looking to get to the bottom
of that event and what was happening
conducting it i'm told um what about uh
carrie johnson two of her mates are in
the garden
well i say i don't know who's there and
i'm gonna wait and what if two of my
mates were in the garden is that still a
work event well one of these i think
we've done enough we've done enough
interviews over the years no you should
know by that i'm not going to get into
hypotheticals because as i said but if
two of the prime ministers beyonce's
mates were in the garden is that still a
work event until we know the facts and
we'll know the facts at the end of the
investigation which won't be very long
the prime minister he wants to see that
come through quickly and as i say
seriously
onto his desk before anybody else knows
about it and he's been made very clear
the prime minister will be publishing
the findings that report will come to
parliament make a statement and then
people will be asked to question him and
get to the see the details of and if the
view is discussion if the view is that
he misled parliament should he resign
well again we're getting into
hypotheticals of a report that we
haven't seen the details of yet i
personally think the prime minister is
the right person to be the prime
minister i think when we look at what
boris johnson has been delivering
is talk about what happened on may of
2020 but also also subsequently after
that allegra stratton resigned just
after she was joking um
it was it was tasteless but she was
joking about a party um martin reynolds
organized a party and he's still in his
post well again smacks of sexism well
allegra made a decision about resigning
and she she responded
well it was allegra who resigned marty
middleton and the details around what
happened around that period both again
with the event on may the 20th the email
and everything around that is exactly
the kind of details that sue graham have
seen the email so no not only only what
i've seen on
the internet and it says we are inviting
you to a party and that is his name at
the bottom yeah and as was making he
actually organized a party
called a party you suggested that people
bring once we've got the detail all of
the details of the context all of these
will happen then we will be able to make
full assessments of what happened who
did what where things work for the party
and then the prime minister as he said
will make that statement looking at the
latest yougov poll um the most recent
poll 10 point lead for labour biggest
gap since 2013 six in ten voters think
the prime minister should resign
including 33 percent of tory voters how
does he recover from this oh look i
think we will be able to go forward and
win a german election i have to say look
with him at the helm yeah absolutely i
think look first of all polling is
always a snapshot at a particular moment
in time and i think it does reflect the
frustration and anger as i said at the
beginning people feel about what they've
seen over the last few days in the last
few weeks arguably but also i think we
have to remember i remember those polls
back in 2012 and as a candidate in 2010
2015 i remember polls tell me i couldn't
win my seat when in fact our majority of
my majority went up so i think we've got
work to do we've got to deliver on
exactly what the prime minister's
outline which is some of the biggest
important reforms dealing with issues
our country could have would have liked
to have dealt with years ago like health
and social care issues in northern
ireland that haven't been dealt with for
decades this is someone who wants to
deal with that and do it in a way that
delivers for everybody in the uk and
that's why i think he will win every
newspaper in the country is not leading
on that today they're leading on the
fact that your leader potentially lied
to parliament well as i say i think
that's why with the polling as it is the
work we've got to do is to focus on as
the prime minister has been all through
this pandemic delivering for people
across the country is why we've got
arguably the most open economy in the
move if moving forward in a way ahead of
most of our competitors because he's
been able to live on the vaccine roll
out boosters at the same time as looking
at those massive reforms we need to do
for health care
fast and loose with the rules when it
suits no he's he's focused on delivering
for the country that's why we're looking
at this massive program of work around
leveling up the biggest investment we've
seen for for decades in our
infrastructure particularly around rail
reforming health and social care in a
way that arguably could have been done
by it should have been done by
governments over the last few decades
let alone the last few years and dealing
with some of those really challenging
issues that are going to make a big
difference in a positive way for people
across the uk but he needs to take the
country with him and he's not going to
be able to take the country with him if
it transpires that he was partying in
number 10 downey street while we were
being told that we had to stay two
meters apart well as i said i think we
need to let the report come through see
the details of the report here
when you can't hide behind this report
coming out anymore but then we'll be
able to talk about the details that are
in that report and actually have that
conversation knowing the facts of what
happened as i said earlier on one of the
things i've learned over the years is
you've got to let these investigations
get to their conclusion so we can all
talk about something when we have the
actual facts of what happens it's
reasonable to ask it's a reasonable
question to ask if he's found to have
misled parliament
the very rules that he wrote himself
means that he has to step down well
that's making a prejudgment on what the
report will find as i said before
because if he isn't found that he misled
parliament then he won't but if he
doesn't the prime minister's outline
that he's his views he hasn't actually
done anything that's outside of the
rules if you look at what the
investigation finds we'll be able to
make people who have to take their own
view of that at the time the prime
minister will make a statement to
parliament as he said he would i think
this prime minister is quite rightly
looking at has continued to look from
when he first came out of hospital and
before he went into hospital with coven
himself
how we deliver for the country keep
people safe get people through get this
to the big bold steps which some people
criticize the time about getting that
vaccine rolled out in europe
sorry highest death rate in europe
but but also actually making sure we've
got that vaccine roll out that has meant
that we've now got the most open economy
we've got more people vaccinated we've
got more people coming through with the
booster that is a phenomenal effort that
people across the country have been part
of doing that he led the way on and at
the same time as that has been able to
start delivering on those other reforms
they're going to make such a big
difference to our country in a positive
way over the next few years and guilty
yesterday fast-tracking um ppe contracts
for buddies
but the court also made it very well
that actually that's not quite what the
court found what the court also saw was
very clear about was that those
contracts would have been awarded they
all went through due process all of
these things go through due process i
know the ministers themselves are not
the people who go through and sign
things off there's a proper process
through the civil service that checks
these things go through due diligence
and actually court also found if i saw
it correctly uh that all of those
contracts would have been awarded anyway
and we have to remember this was at a
time where the prime minister the health
secretary and others were doing
everything they can to get the ppu at
the time were quite likely challenging
us about to make sure that our health
service and people across the country
could be safe and having parties in the
garden um
isn't this putting an undue amount of
pressure on a civil servant she's
judging jury well as i said i've worked
with uh sue groud a few hours she's an
immensely more than capable person she
did a phenomenal job for the uk civil
service and the northern ireland civil
service i have to say but she was
working there for a couple of years i
have absolute confidence that sugray
will be working uh without feel favor
she will go through this in detail and
she will produce her report and i'm sure
she has got the more the the the
excellently uh constructive shoulders do
we have to manage that you're here this
morning um defending the prime minister
some of your other colleagues have been
doing the same where was rishi sunak
yesterday well as as i said i was in
belfast yesterday she was on a
long-range uh visit to yesterday
i've seen rishi himself working
consistently hand-in-hand with the prime
minister for the benefit of people
across the country working together
focused on working together and i and
and i think it's very clear if she has
got that look at his tweet let's see
what he said um uh yesterday when
everybody was uh being called in to try
to support the prime minister i've been
on a visit all day today continuing work
on our plans for jobs as well as meeting
mps to discuss the energy situation
hardly um a fulsome support of the prime
minister he goes on to say the pm was
right to apologize and i support his
request for patience while sue gray
carries out her inquiry not as false as
your support
well i've as i said i've seen rishi
working with the prime minister they
were absolutely hand-in-hand for people
across the country i know richie has got
support for the prime minister i
appreciate that there are times where
things aren't on twitter or wording
particularly on twitter people take a
view but i i see a chance who's been
working with the prime minister focused
on delivering people across the country
that's what he was doing yesterday i'm
feeling a bit of a flashback coming from
when john major had a problem with his
wisdom too so he couldn't come out and
support margaret thatcher when she
needed it most
well um i i i'd say that's a bit before
my my time what i've saw
[Laughter]
what i've seen yesterday and i've seen
consistently through this is a cabinet
they've been completely joined up
working together our focus all the way
through this has been around making sure
we're making decisions based on the
advice that we get that in the best
interest of people across the country
all through that i've seen colleagues
supporting working with as i do now a
prime minister's absolute focus has been
on delivering for the best interest of
the country and trying to do that not
just with covid but as i say on those
wider issues during code we're able to
continue to progress on those wider
issues will be of benefit for us and i
think we'll see the benefit over the
next couple years and that's why i
believe boyce johnson will be the prime
minister who wins the next general
election let me just put this to you
finally before i let you go you're
working all day in the office you go
outside when people have to be two
meters apart and only can see one other
person you see a trestle table with
peanuts and crisps and sausage rolls
whatever else they were eating about 40
people some people who are not actually
members of staff from downing street you
think oh i'm going to have 25 minutes
drink with these people i'm not going to
ask them to go back inside i'm just
going to go back inside again and you
you buy all of that well there's two or
three things within that i'll say that
first of all this is about and it's one
it's difficult to explain but the
reality of how downing street works and
the garden is actually integral part of
downing street i absolutely can see the
logic of the prime minister going
outside to talk to the staff we've been
working together and focused on things
around covert all day to thank the stars
always watch well this is a bit of a
give me because why he is rightly said
about all the booze with hindsight it's
not something he would do but again
you're tempting me into details of an
investigation that the investigation
will get to that we're not fully aware
of yet and once we get those details we
can have a follow-up conversation the
prime minister himself has been very
clear he will come to parliament make a
statement and people will be able to
quiz him on that i'll look forward to
chatting to you again then for now i
must let you go thank you very much
indeed brandon you do look great fourth
stone both gone
well done thank you let's have a look at
some of these mornings front pages for
you now and they don't make good reading
for the prime minister the guardian
describes boris johnson's future as
being on a knife edge with his apology
doing little to quell unrest on the
conservative back benches
the mirror is calling the pm
a total disgrace they say the nation is
in outrage
the mail says tory attempts at damage
control are the beginning of operation
save boris with reports suggesting the
likes of liz tross are standing by the
pm
for now
and the national in scotland doesn't
hold back branding the pm
a liar
now what next will prince andrew after a
u.s judge rejected his attempt to have
the sexual assault lawsuit against him
thrown out
uh sadia is with us at windsor castle
this morning hi sally good morning to
you um difficult day for the prince
again
good morning k yes it's worrying times
for prince andrew because all of his
defenses so far have been rejected but
we do know a few things for certain for
for one thing i think is important to
say that there's no extradition in a
civil case so we're not going to see
anything like that happen with him but
what will happen next is
most likely to be a trial uh now uh with
a with a trial prince andrew will be
asked to go there because the u.s court
does have jurisdiction uh over this
matter there is every chance of course
that he uh will
reject that and not and and not go and
if he doesn't then that in that case
there would be a what is called a
default judgment now there are some
options he could engage with this he
could uh
choose not to engage with it there are
lots of things but we also don't know
what virginia g frey wants exactly last
night her lawyers said that money isn't
going to be enough that she's after
justice she wants vindication not just
for herself but also for other victims
that could be in the form of a public
apology or an admission of guilt or
something like that well prince andrew
denies all the claims against him and
buckingham palace uh has
refused to comment on an ongoing legal
matter
okay thanks so much indeed sadie thank
you still to come on the program for you
this morning later this hour speaking to
legal commentator joshua rosenberg as
prince andrew faces the trial over
allegations he sexually assaulted
virginia dufrey when she was 17.
as boris johnson faces growing calls for
his resignation for attending a lock
down breaking party we'll speak to a
woman who couldn't say goodbye to her
father due to covered restrictions
and later this hour i'm going to be
speaking to a pollster at opinion about
the prime minister
and his falling approval ratings
meantime the uk's third largest gas and
electricity supplier is to axe a quarter
of its workforce talking about ovo
energy uh helena is here tell us more
good morning morning kay yeah really a
sense i think that this developing
energy crisis that we've heard so much
about in recent months is really now
coming knocking at the doors of some of
the uk's biggest energy suppliers so ovo
energy a real household name the uk's
third biggest energy supplier we
understand our colleague mark kleinman
our city editor broke this last night we
understand that this morning it will
move to announce that it's axing 1700
jobs around a quarter of its workforce
because of this ongoing energy crisis
now it's already been a pretty torrid
week for over you might remember earlier
in the week uh they got into a lot of
trouble sending out that communication
that blog to some of its customers
saying oh you can try and keep warm by
hugging your pets or eating porridge or
doing star jumps um lots of people said
that's extremely insensitive given the
soaring bills that people are facing for
that he did apologize uh the ceo uh
stephen fitzpatrick and actually he was
really praised for uh the sort of the
genuine nature of that um apology uh so
it's been a torrid week for them um but
there's a few operational reasons why
they might be looking to cut down some
of their workforce things like
consolidation of sites and automation
but look there's no escaping the fact
the key reason for this is that soaring
price of wholesale gas
the energy companies face this position
where the price that they have to buy
their gas for is so very high record
highs but they are limited in what they
can charge their customers by that off
gem price cap so they say under these
two things although that price cap's
there to protect customers they simply
can't balance the books and there's been
a swathe of other energy companies 25
and counting at the moment who have gone
under and for ovo this big powerful
company uh to be laying off a quarter of
its stuff i think that really says
something very significant about just
how challenging these times are worth
saying that price cap unfortunately for
customers is going to go up they're
going to review it in february it will
come into play in april and that will
make a difference but for these
companies uh too little too late
essentially and of course it's going to
be extremely difficult for those
consumers who might face bills of
potentially up to 2000 pounds a year
likely and worth saying finally this
really ups the pressure uh on the
government because for all these
companies that go under for all these
energy companies they're in trouble the
people who ultimately pay are the
consumers and as we know lots of
families facing a terrible terrible cost
of lifting crisis at the moment so
really a serious trouble indeed we're
talking to somebody a little bit later
on actually who is really struggling
with their bills at the moment goodness
knows what's going to happen come april
for now thanks very much indeed meantime
novak djokovic has been included in the
draw of the aussie open which starts
next week but it's still not clear
whether the defending champion will be
allowed to take part and the draw itself
was not without drama drama even as
guineas australia's joel phillip has the
latest from melbourne
when this draw was due to be announced
the media were let into the room some of
them were able to walk in and then
officials stopped them and the rest of
them were not able to walk in everyone
was drawn then back out of the room and
they said that the press conference has
been postponed indefinitely so somewhat
chaotic scenes that we saw there in the
just here at melbourne park it was a
another dramatic day of events in the
meanwhile at rod lehman arena um no that
djokovic himself was training for really
the third day of daily training sessions
ahead of the australian open which is
due to start on the 17th which is a
monday of course the situation here
continues with the australian government
not being clear if they are going to
cancel his visa or not but there are
reports here that if that would likely
occur that indeed his lawyers would
attempt to get an injunction filed
within the court and if that was
successful the court case could be drawn
into next week which means novak
djokovic could be the world's number one
seed playing in the australian open and
then possibly kicked out in the middle
of the tournament
looking at some of the day's other main
stories for you now the charity age uk
says rising energy bills could trigger a
national emergency for millions of
pensioners they've written to the
government urging drastic action to
mitigate what they called a looming
crisis
a man used a hammer to attack a statue
outside the bbc's broadcasting house in
central london before the fire service
helped get him down a petition has
called for the removal of the statue
because the sculptor eric gill was
accused of sexually abusing his own
daughters
mps have found that people living in
england's most deprived communities were
46 more likely to die from covet than
those in the rest of the country a joint
report by the all party parliamentary
group for left behind neighborhoods and
the northern health science alliance
said people in poorer communities worked
longer hours in public facing jobs and
suffered greater ill health
the uk's recorded the highest daily
number of covert deaths in almost 11
months
almost 130 000 new cases of coronavirus
have been reported there have been
398
more deaths it takes the number of those
who died within 28 days of a positive
covid test to 151 0007.
now in argentina two police officers
have managed to save the life of a young
girl who was found choking in the street
check these pictures out the officers
were on patrol when they spotted the
child and jumped out of the vehicle to
help
there you go they performed cpr honor in
the squad car with the girl's frantic
mum in the back the officers sped
through the traffic to the nearest
hospital for help they managed to revive
the 18 month old girl during the journey
before rushing her inside where she
later made a full
recovery quick look at the weather
[Music]
look forward to brighter skies
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
high pressure means the next few days
will be mainly settled with a risk of
fog and frost southern parts will have a
calm frosty start today with dense
freezing fog patches bringing the chance
of travel disruption
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
tributes have been paid to american
music icon ronnie spector who has died
at the age of 78. here we go
[Music]
she was the lead singer of the 60s girl
group the ronettes who had hits with be
my baby that one and walking in the rain
in a statement her family said her
joyful sound playful nature and magical
presence will live on in all who knew
heard or saw her she formed the group
with her sister and her cousin
this the moment military police in
brazil rescued a dog trapped in a car in
30 degree eat heat don't have got
somebody else's teeth in today officers
had to break the window to get her out
quite right too and they cooled her down
with some bottled water the owner said
he'd gone to lunch and left the dog in
the car because the restaurant didn't
accept animals
he's been arrested for look at her
little face arrested for mistreatment
the dog called kyra was taken to a vet
clinic and is said to be doing well
uh let's have a look at some of these
amazing photographs i'm going to get up
and show these to you it's a beautiful
dawning as you can see in the express
newspaper uh for you this beautiful shot
caught the magnificent sunrise over
stonehenge yesterday morning as a frost
covered the ground the calm before the
political storm some might ponder but
stonehenge wasn't the only place to see
red sky at morning yesterday this shot
shows the sun rising behind the
beautiful the scent mary and all saints
church close to where mary queen of
scots was executed in here in
northamptonshire another sensational
photograph this time in the guardian now
i'm sure many parents dread taking their
young children for their jabs this
picture in the telegraph says it all
this child is getting his kovid jab in
indonesia look at his little face
um starting mass vaccinations in
children aged six to 11 there we love
this one top of the popes in the sun
pope francis has been seen visiting his
local record shop
in rome some of the suggestions of
records he was looking for
included
judas priest heaven 17
nazareth bit of all saints there and at
the top number one genesis
still to come on the program for us this
morning more reaction as prince andrew
fails in his bid to have a sex abuse
lawsuit dismiss that come
[Music]
hello everybody top stories for you so
far this morning on the program boris
johnson's future is in the balance as he
faces calls to quit from his own
backbenches
virginia duprey's lawyer says she wants
justice as a judge clears the way for
prince andrew to face a civil sex
assault case
uk's third largest gas and electricity
supplier ovo energy is to cut a quarter
of its workforce
northern ireland secretary brandon lewis
has this morning defended the prime
minister after his apology for attending
a party in downing street during
lockdown in may of 2020. boris johnson
is facing a revolt within the
conservative party with growing calls
for his resignation but mr lewis has
told us the prime minister is still the
right man for the job
what i've seen yesterday and i've seen
consistently through this is a cabinet
they've been completely joined up
working together our focus all the way
through this has been around making sure
we're making decisions based on the
advice that we get that are in the best
interest of people across the country
all through that i've seen colleagues
supporting working as i do now a prime
minister's absolute focus has been on
delivering for the best interest of the
country and trying to do that not just
with kovid but as i said on those wider
issues doing code we're able to continue
to progress on those wider issues will
be of benefit for us and i think we'll
see the benefit over the next couple
years and that's why i believe boris
johnson will be the prime minister who
wins the next general election
uh tomorrow's with us on downing street
um they're
uh circling the wagons is that how i
should put it uh tomorrow what do you
think
i think so okay we're seeing operations
shore up the prime minister with brandon
lewis and other members of the cabinet
tweeting their support messaging other
mps to support the prime minister at
this difficult time and coming into tv
studios to say look he's apologized and
we now need to move on but of course the
problem is that the apology or the sorry
not sorry we heard from the prime
minister in parliament yesterday didn't
go down very well with many of his
colleagues brandon lewis conceded there
that there is a lot we don't know about
this party including exactly how many
people attended who organized it and
whether that important question of
whether the prime minister
misled parliament by saying that there
weren't any parties and that none of the
rules were broken that is in itself a
resigning issue so a lot of tory mps are
weighing things up at the moment i think
the prime minister yesterday bought
himself some time mps will want to wait
and most mps want to wait until that
report by sue gray the civil servant
leading it comes out four mps have so
far called for him to resign already the
scottish conservatives are in open
revolt against the prime minister but a
lot of mps are weighing up their options
seeing what comes out in that report and
it will be tory mps and the cabinet who
now decide whether there is a leadership
challenge after that whether their most
electrically successful prime minister
for 30 years has now become a liability
but it was very striking yesterday that
rishi sunak the chancellor who lives
next door at number 11 was absent
yesterday and when he finally did tweet
something last night it was not very
supportive of the prime minister no for
now tomorrow thanks tomorrow's take at
nine o'clock very much looking forward
to hearing what uh tomorrow's take is on
events of the day and we've got for
labour lisanne jonyas
at the top of the next hour so more on
that to come
meantime legal commentator joshua
rosenberg is with us now hi joshua lots
to talk about let's start with the prime
minister should we um given what you
heard from him yesterday did that sound
like a pretty solid defense at the
dispatch box
well what the law says is that or what
it said at that time was that you had to
stay at home you were allowed to go out
it was a reasonable excuse
if you were working if you had to work
and it wasn't reasonably possible for
you to work at a place where you were
living now obviously people working in
downing street
were able to work there i'm sure it
would have been difficult for them to
work from home so the real question is
whether when they were in the garden at
six o'clock in the evening whether that
was part of work or not work or
effectively a party and that's something
that if it ever came to court the judge
would have to decide but it's obviously
very tricky if you'd asked the prime
minister at that time whether it was
lawful for people to go into a garden
and have drinks in those circumstances
even if the garden was part of a
government building i suspect he would
have said no
what did it say the law at the time
about how far apart people had to be if
they were outside
they had to be socially distanced as you
say
and there were limits on the number of
people so it really does depend on
whether he can come within the law which
said this was working there was no doubt
that although it was a good idea to be
socially distanced if you had to work
closely to somebody
then that was possible broadcasting went
on government went on hospitals worked
so working was permitted the real
question i think is whether this counted
as work or not uh certainly it would
have been better if they had been
socially distanced but i don't think
that any prosecution would go into that
sort of detail it's really whether it
was within uh the law as laid down at
the time
somebody else who's feeling the heat but
obviously not sweating is um prince
andrew what did yesterday's judgment
mean for him
well the judge was not being asked to
decide whether the allegations made by
virginia jeffrey against prince andrew
were true or not all the judge had to
decide
was whether he was entitled to claim
that her argument was legally
insufficient and he relied on this
agreement that she had reached in 2009
with jeffrey epstein
and he said that was something he could
rely on to stop the case in its tracks
now that was thrown out the reason for
that is that this uh agreement wasn't as
clear
as prince andrew hoped it was he said
that it covered him the judge said it
was ambiguous because it was ambiguous
it didn't count although it is still
possible for him to bring this back if
the case goes to trial at a future date
he also has to talk to the fbi or
certainly they want to talk to him about
their investigation that is separate to
this isn't it that's completely separate
this is a civil claim as you know this
is a claim for damages brought by
virginia jeffrey against him there was
an element of the criminal law involved
in it but that was one of the arguments
was thrown out by judge kaplan yesterday
i'm sure that the fbi will be very
interested in what happens in this civil
claim equally if they are going after
jeffrey epstein's associates and they've
already convicted gilain maxwell
i suppose they might start with
associates who are in the united states
and don't pose problems of extradition
which is what would happen i suppose if
there were ever to be criminal charges
against prince andrew
and just a quick thought before i let
you go if possible please as far as um
prince andrew's family is concerned i'm
thinking particularly about his ex-wife
and indeed his two daughters one of whom
he said he was at a pizza express with
her for a party so he couldn't have been
where others had said he was could they
find themselves in a position where they
are also having to answer questions
under oath
this all depends on whether the case
settled now virginia jiffrey's lawyer
david boyes was speaking yesterday he
wasn't as dogmatic as some people
thought he might be he said that
virginia jeffrey wants to resolve the
case but he certainly didn't say that
she's insisting on her day in court i'm
sure she would want an apology i'm sure
she would want compensation now if the
prince is willing to go down that road
uh and after all he uh david bowie's the
lawyer for virginia geoffrey said that
mediation was offered to the prince last
year and rejected
if prince andrew is willing to go down
that road that would spare him having to
give evidence and his family being
called as potential witnesses either by
giving what are called depositions
recorded
statements in advance or indeed having
to come to court
thanks very much indeed joshua thanks
for the update um sir anthony seldon uh
joining us he is a contemporary
historian of course uh good morning to
you anthony thank you for joining us can
you think of any time when the monarchy
in recent history has been under this
much pressure
um well the monarchy has been under
pressure case throughout history at
different points
but certainly
it was some great pressure obviously in
the 1990s
when
in a way a more significant
marriage for the monarchy of prince
charles
was in question with diana because he
will become king and andrew will never
become king so
the monarchy being under pressure is a
pretty much a constant throughout
history but of course it's under
it's uh i think less the monarchy
than
prince andrew him itself i don't think
the institution is under threat at the
moment no
um
except all of the other the other points
that you were making there at this this
one much more
unsavory
uh the history of the monarchy has been
full of unsafe i'm not trying to excuse
i was trying to just
say factually uh that uh there has been
uh a long history of uh of uh lesser
royals and indeed sometimes the monarch
um particularly before they became
monarch as for example the case with
edward vii not behaving uh well at all
so um if you know it's look kay it's not
a great moment for anybody uh in the
royal family um
and uh it's a very sad thing that this
is happening for the royal family and
for the country obviously without doubt
given some of the comparisons that
you're making there sir anthony um how
do you think history will look back on
prince andrew
well i there is uh somebody who
obviously will wait to see what what
happens
uh my
own view of him is that he has done a
lot of good things he's tried uh and his
uh charitable
uh and educational activities have often
and business activities of
um for example encouraging entrepreneurs
have been uh submerged um in and very
understandably in what's happening
now
uh i think a lot depends on what happens
what the outcome is
uh i think he should uh withdraw until
the outcome is clear
and then to see if he can rebuild um his
life in some way or other so that people
remember the good things that he tried
to do
in his life and not just uh this uh
episode which uh would otherwise uh
stain and block out uh the good things
that he tried to do so i'm just trying
to give a balanced uh view there uh of
somebody who clearly um it would seem
has made some significant mistakes uh
although
the case has to be heard uh but who has
uh
a hinterland also of things he's tried
to do
okay given um comparison well not
comparisons but people who have
made significant mistakes certainly the
prime minister was apologizing for one
that he made yesterday in june of last
year you said that the prime minister
might be on track to become one of the
landmark prime ministers in british
history do you still feel the same way
today
well
that is
the tragedy of boris johnson isn't it
that
he had he was on track um
with brexit not that i personally agreed
with brexit but that's a historic move
it's uh the most
uh significant uh move on foreign policy
taken by a prime
minister uh
for 50 years so that's a historic event
isn't it and he's coping uh and managing
the response to brexit the greatest
health crisis for a hundred years these
things k are the stuff on history so he
was on track uh he needed to stay on the
track and not come off the tracks and
uh the current episodes uh with the
parties on top of other
uh
errors that he's made uh significantly
uh are going to derail him and in that
case he will be remembered uh far more
for the things that he's done wrong and
the reasons that he left
being prime minister rather than
uh the things the historic steps that he
took but i mean history will always
remember boris johnson as the man for
better or worse who took us britain out
of the eu and the man who was there
uh for uh the pandemic or certainly the
early and perhaps mid-stages of it
historic uh event so uh it does seem
that unless uh has the apology been
enough who knows uh jury is still out
waiting for the supreme report if he
does uh get through this and that's
obviously a big if uh will he be able to
rebuild
his own uh brand and provide the steady
uh focused leadership uh and a clear
strategy for the country and uh building
uh back and leveling up that they don't
just become slogans but become really
substantial
ideas will he be capable of doing that
and i think it needs to be a far more
serious considered
prime minister who comes out of this so
uh
this will either be the event that sees
him off or
which uh really makes him realize that
he simply cannot uh carry on as prime
minister uh in the way that he has it is
the most serious job in the entire
country and this is the greatest health
and could be
economic crisis as well
uh for uh decades
that was a false answer uh we very much
appreciate it thank you very much indeed
for joining us much appreciated
thank you
okay so um lots of the papers this
morning are absolutely filled to the
brim with what happened in downing
street on the 20th of may 2020 jean
adamson
is families for justice spokesperson um
hello to you gene you've heard what the
pm has had to say how are you feeling
about that this morning
um yesterday was a very upsetting
experience
for marine families i think all over the
land
um boris johnson has not um reassured us
in any sense or more fashion
we feel
very badly let down
um and
we we are um you know very very upset um
yesterday's performance um in the house
of commons uh was nothing more than that
it was a self-serving exercise
where the prime minister
is his main focus really was to protect
himself
um and practice by some more time
the apology is hollow um he's not sorry
he's sorry he got caught
tell me about um your dad and what
happened aldrich although you you knew i
think it's cleo didn't you
yes yes that's right um cleo my dad uh
was a windrush pioneer um he came from
barbados in the 1950s
um settled here worked hard all his life
um he was a a musician
um he was a family man and he
he was a a hearty robust character and
we loved him dearly and and miss him
um so much
and um he died in a care home
of covert in
april 15th of april 2020.
we lost him and um
you know it's been a very very
challenging time for us since then and
you know our my grief is compounded by
these
you know
revelations that keep coming these
scandals
you know
um and we lost you know we lost our
loved ones uh
in very difficult circumstances
and um
it's just um it's heartbreaking really
that you know we
are still
having these um you know these these
scandals and you know these very hurtful
things are happening
that that are just very upsetting for
all of us
a few days before
that downing street party
i was standing at my father's brave side
um a few of us were huddled around the
graveside um i wasn't able to give my
father the funeral that he would have
wanted
so because you know we were subject
clearly to um you know the rules
and had to make many sacrifices at this
time so to hear that um
down the street where planning a party
at that time
is is just absolutely you know it's
disgraceful the behavior is disgraceful
gene um
he's a handsome devil your dad isn't he
thank you for sharing the pictures uh
with us our thoughts very much uh with
you this morning i think i just saw a
little smile on your face then when we
were reflecting on your dad thank you
for joining us much appreciated thank
you
thank you
so look at the latest approval rating
should we for the prime minister his
popularity has plummeted yougov poll for
sky news found that a third of
conservative party members think the pm
should resign and a yougov poll for the
times has put labour 10 points ahead of
the tories for the first time in almost
a decade let's speak to chris curtis
head of political polling and opinion
research hi chris
um thank you talk to you this morning um
interpret some of these figures for us
if you would
um well it's not good for the prime
minister and for the government um these
are
pretty abysmal approval ratings and
opinion polling we're seeing across the
board i mean just two years ago remember
the prime minister went down to a
landslide victory against conservatives
11.12 points ahead of them when he won
you know
50 60 seats straight directly off the
labor party to now be 10 points behind
them is quite a dramatic shift to have
happened over two years alongside that
what we're seeing is the prime
minister's worst approval ratings yet
they're now if anything slightly worse
than teresa theresa may's approval
ratings were when she was booted out of
office
in 2019 and i think one of the key stats
we've seen from our opinion research
recently just 12 of people think that
the prime minister is telling the truth
about the parties that were happening in
downing street that's fewer than the
number of people who think that the moon
landings were fake so wherever you look
whichever opinion poll you look at
whichever question you're asking at the
moment it's all coming back showing
negative numbers for the conservatives
and boris johnson what about liz tross
and rishi sunak what are the numbers
saying for them
so i mean throughout the entire pandemic
and it's still true today rishi sunak
has been one of the most popular
politicians in the country obviously
giving lots of people giving lots of
money to people um when they're you know
potentially facing an economic crisis
because they haven't um because they're
they're not able to go and do their job
obviously makes you incredibly popular
and i think that's still true at the
moment what we're seeing is while the
prime minister's personal popularity has
plummeted slightly more people still say
they have a favorable view of rishi soon
after an unfavorable view and i think if
you were to sort of try and speculate
and it's hard as to which conservative
leader would potentially go down best
with the public there's lots of reasons
why that might change but at the moment
on paper it certainly looks like rishi
tsunak's the most popular liz trusts on
the other hand is slightly less well
known so it's very very hard to work out
how she will go down because you know
somewhere around half the public still
don't have don't know enough about her
to form that form of strong opinion very
very popular with the backbenchers
though isn't she in the grassroots
touries let's see how that develops what
about labor what are labour's weaknesses
right now
yeah i mean obviously when we're talking
about how badly things are going for the
conservatives and the government we
should also point out that the polling
shows that the labour party isn't a
mirror image of that while things are
going well boris johnson's approval
ratings have gone through the floor we
haven't seen a dramatic increase in
kiyostama's approval ratings at all in
most cases more people still say they
have a negative view of him than a
positive view of him but i think there's
another metric as well that we're
measuring on the labour party that i
think is particularly important and
that's to do with managing the economy
despite the fact that we're well over a
decade on
from the financial crisis more people
most people still say they don't trust
they think the labour party is competent
enough to take over and run the economy
and i think until they start to fix that
even when the conservatives are going
through crisis like this there still
won't be enough people who automatically
go labour is the default option labor is
ready for government i'm now ready to
vote for the labour party so while you
might see these temporary temporary
things in response to polls i think if
labour wants to be confident that they
can take the reins off the conservatives
next election they really need to
rebuild up that economic competence
metric quick thought before i let you go
lisa nandy's on the program in a minute
how popular is she
uh well again she's one of those people
she's a little bit but she's yeah she's
like many people in the shadow cabinet
it's very very hard to get cut free lots
of people still don't have a strong
opinion of her having said that of those
who do have an opinion of lisa and andy
um she is fairly popular so more people
do say they like her and dislike her
probably because she's from wigan i
would have thought it's good to talk to
you thank you very much indeed for the
analysis i don't know why you're
laughing thanks very much much
appreciated thank you have a look at
these pictures should we um in our
screen can you imagine being a
first-time mom
to 16 babies that's just what happened
to unity the three-year-old german
shepherd guide dog it's the biggest
litter the sight loss charity guide dogs
has ever seen
in its 60-year breeding program the
puppies were fathered by trigger a
golden retriever he's showing off and
the charity hopes this means they will
have the loyalty and drive of mom and
friendly nature of dad
how cute is that a newborn baby
abandoned in temperatures of minus 20
degrees has been rescued by a group of
teenagers fabulous stuff five teenagers
found the baby in a cardboard box in a
remote siberian village where she was
rushed to hospital by one of the
teenagers parents police are looking for
the mum the infant is said to be doing
well renee litvinov who discovered the
baby says
he just had to save her
we found the box somewhere around here
she was about this large
the baby was inside covered in some kind
of thin blankets
well that's it for this hour but coming
up the northern ireland secretary
brandon lewis tells me that boris
johnson will win the next election
despite a revolt from within his own
party and plummeting popularity over the
downing street parties we've been
looking at the polls there haven't we he
is incredibly unpopular at the moment
but he did apologize in the house of
commons yesterday will that be enough
when we pressed the government on that
they were telling us we need to wait for
sue gray they're probably the most
famous woman in the country at the
moment she's likely to report back
within the next week to 10 days
continuing coverage here on skype
[Music]